favini speedo facendo finta di cantare
wanna be delle spice girls michiara
questa sala cosa più vergognosa della
storia
[Musica]
signorini ma che stai facendo quella a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a che sono
video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo
blog si sono pigro e non c'ho voglia di
mettere la maglietta ok non c'è ragazzi
come al solito partiamo che la fan arte
della settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da asia che ha fatto storia
campo la tra l'altro celle e anche fatto
senza lo sfondo quindi è bellissimo
ragazzi dalle mie guance rosse sono
bellissimi avi hai vinto qualsiasi sarei
e ripartire con le news
credo che of the net sia più espressivo
di mio papà e vado che la prima ragazza
dunque sabato prossimo il 13 dicembre
sarà il motor show di bologna il web
show world l'avevo già scritto tutto
quindi senza problemi l'unica cosa
ragazzi se volete votarmi verve inserì
web awards
lascio linking descrizione cercate la
mia faccia lo sito fa vijecnica tenta
sobota in rosso così vi do tanti bei
biscotti promesso la seconda news
ragazze che s'è concluso visto che ve lo
state chiedendo tutti se concluso il
contest delle magliette quindi quelle
delle 100 magliette dei pokémon quindi
basta ai disegni perché me ne sono
arrivati 5.000 nostro sito qua quanto me
ne sono il nostro scattata la sono 5.264
disegni 5
rendetevi conto questo è per
l'entusiasmo di questi 5.000 quantica
nome nella memoria di un bruco sento
vinceranno la maglietta ragazzi ove la
vorrei regalare a tutti quanti la
maglietta per ora la nintendo che ha
organizzato come questo contest che c'è
anche anni devo ringraziare anche la
nintendo per averci fornito le magliette
tutto le ha fatte stampare cento quindi
ragazzi
manderò cento ai creatori delle 100 fan
art più belle che mi sono arrivati di
queste cinque non me lo ricordo lunghe
ragazzi per riuscire a dare un po di
soddisfazione a tutti quanti
tutte le tutte quante le fanatiche mi
avete passato tutte le tengo e
possibilità anche io il futuro elementa
nei video quindi non vi preoccupate mi
sono arrivati dei capolavori che devo
fare come posta sono bellissimi alcuni
sono veramente bellissimi sono tutti
quanti belli ragazzi non è che alcuni mi
hanno disegnato tipo pikachu così però
sono belli anche questi grazie come
ultima news ragazzi siccome adesso il
periodo natalizio quindi feste panetto
avercene birra vodka e quelle no ho
deciso che inizierò a fare gli speciali
ragazzi quindi dovessimo avanti
aspettando non ve lo dico ovviamente non
riescono ma farò dei nuovi speciali
visto che da un secolo che non ne faccio
uno i ragazzi preparatevi perché sarà
fantastico e non vi dico nulla comunque
vedrete voi concludo qualche le news e
quindi sono veramente sono convinto la
mente contento ragazzi di tutto questo
supporto veramente grazie grazie grazie
non sovrano ogni volta rimango senza
parole ma tanto ora non c'è da dopo il
milione ragazzi non c'è più un traguardo
preciso va beh sì milione e 500 mila al
milioni però non c'è più un traguardo
che dico oddio cioè ogni volta che
guardo il contatore dico sempre oddio
quindi io farei ogni iscritto uno
speciale solo che sono un essere umano
sapete dormo anch'io quindi non lo
faccio però quindi ragazzi veramente
viering vi ringrazio di cuore grazie
grazie grazie ho già detto grazie ma
hanno detto quindi grazie grazie detto
questo ragazzi che possiamo stare affari
risponde non è uno scatto aggiornava
l'ha fatto la faccio prima a fare
risponde a fuori dire fare risponde
prima adesso faccio prima fuori distanza
la faccia famiglia armi nella marca vada
io non ho mai sentito la marca che si
chiama carmine tipo nike però vabbè
avete presente le battute pessime che mi
andrebbe di lancio di un barile addosso
ecco potete farlo fa vi risponde perché
hai sempre una bottiglia di te sulla
scrivania allora invariati questa è una
domanda ingegnosa perché berna
è pubblico priamo che sennò pubblicità
co illuminati
[Musica]
tengo sempre le bottigliette di te sulla
scrivania perché mi serve un qualcosa da
bere ogni tanto perché se no le mie
corde vocali si staccano escono e vanno
a fare un party hard fuori quindi è
normale
solo che io non vivo di acqua view dite
sempre stato così sempre stato così poi
risponde farli rispondi alle domande con
l'altro fa vj la prova finale che ne
esiste solo uno ma basta regala questa
storia basta cioè iniziano nel posto per
farvi vieni un attimo perché mica
scassano tra pavia vieni ti faccio vieni
qua avete scassato le palle e non si può
varda io ti dico non lo so me lo
chiedono
devo dire beh dovete farci l'abitudine a
sa cosa regala il normale c'è vabbè
comunque rispondi a rispondiamo alle
domande sta per me facciamo insieme
vabbè facciamo insieme ship break poi
risponde farina 6 picanto the walking
dead
vai tu vado io no vabbè si dai
io seguo parecchio noi siamo parecchio
the walking dead perché cioè a me piace
molto l'apocalittico si sia camp nou a
me piace anche perché c'è daryl io sono
innamorato è un maschio quindi non tanto
però sono innamorato di dei caratteri di
daring mi piace un casino quindi non so
io seguo anche perché alte piace se
minchia daryl insegnano nei fatti non è
veramente poi mi piace the walking dead
in generale come ha detto lui per sé
sicuro state tante ma un attimo al cesso
che mi sto pagando una figura che fai
google sei tranquillo io ti aspetto
quando grazie a sé come ci va dritto di
cagate marchi
lascio per vado avanti io che mail
francesco occhipinti puoi toglierti le
cuffie solo per due secondi ok ma io
vorrei capire queste cose perché
continuerò non capire le prove
adesso le rimetto sono passati due
secondi e detto queste ragazzine che
possiamo passare allo scarpaccio dei
pacchi alla fine perché era una è una
punizione questa volta comunque va bene
stato quello ancora a cagare
macché eccola era un immenso ragazzi
storico carta igienica questa e carta
igienica pro e bella porto dal più
piccolo perché è caduta quindi ha la
precedenza per questo nel primo c'è
all'interno una cassetta una carta una
cassetta di buzz lightyear ti ringrazio
perché è una perché dato ragazzi che ci
credi attorno shop ce l'avevo queste che
andavo pazza e buzz lightyear la piccola
non si vede che vado fatto io l'ho
sempre sempre che mi stava accadendo
porca [ __ ] cat l'ho preso e cielo
ancora nella scatola proprio perché mica
lo tengo benissimo non proprio benissimo
lo adoro ragazzi passiamo al prossimo
che è una roba è enorme anche quelle che
quello è neanche più grosso è bello ho
visto la luce a carte di paul cene
quanti caschi sono qua del mio addio
dopo di che i ragazzi c'è una rosa di
babbo in come si chiama di babbo natale
questo è bello sembra che due babbi
natale vogliano stuprarmi da un momento
all'altro bellissimo ai ragazzi ci sono
due così che cos'è questo delle borchie
bello lui se mi stavano per fare il tipo
dark tipo così sono molto belle grande
adesso sono più credibile se vado in
giro e prendo a cazzotti e personale beh
grazie molto figo dopodiché ragazzi dei
corsi che sembrano dei ringo che non
aprirò preco paura di vedere che cosa
c'e dentro prodotto non esplosivo
boom
cristo ce l'ha scritto non esclusivo
porca [ __ ]
[Musica]
porca la eva la mamma [ __ ] che
cazzo è successo io c'ho queste ti vengo
a cercare molto prest madonna to sporco
che bordello pure sul muro pure sul
[ __ ] muro fantastico grazie
dopodichè ragazzi cè un primi regala i
cioccolatini come se potesse in qualche
modo risolvere la cag ata che ha fatto
grazie zio molto gentile perfetto
ragazzi ora che c'è tutta questa bella
merda sulla mia stima a dona che il
bordello ma non ce la farò mai a da
pulire rimarrà così per sempre
e poi ci sono le carte degli anni degli
amici cuccioli grazie a sì sì questo è
proprio un cucciolo troll dispetto che
cazzo di cuccioli è questo quindi
ragazzi adesso farà il blog così perché
vi devo far vedere la merda che c'è
sulla mia scrivania crisi ragazzi visto
la situazione in cui sono è visto che
non posso più aprire la mia scrivania è
stata occupata da coriandoli e babbi
natale di cioccolato direi che posso
passare la farina manda e conclude più
perché non ce la farò mai più a pulire
questa merda se mia madre adesso vede
come ridotto la mia stanza è stato bello
vede conoscervi i ragazzi fuori domanda
e la favi domanda di oggi ed ha visto
che nello scorso vlog detto che mi plan
sono un casino mi sposo tutto quando ho
detto che leggo maze runner 90 si
chiamano urban fantasy tanto me l'avete
anche detto vi ringrazio perché non lo
sapevo e mi va bene qual è il genere che
vi piace di più a voi in generale tipo
ines o romantico non credo proprio se mi
date anche un consiglio su come togliere
sta merda sono anche più contento quindi
grazie ragazzi di avermi mandato questo
schifo come assetto savino e piace
ancora sta roba addosso fa un po picchio
qualcuno cioè mio padre mi armi mi fa
arrestare appena mi vede così quindi
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto molto il
tasso documento mi piace anche a parlare
facebook e come da video tratta
descrizione so se volessi di scrivete
ministri vediamo il prossimo livello
ragazzi
chi sa che cazzo è sto bordello